hi i'm megan from khan academy and in
this video we're going to walk you
through the learner or student
experience
at khan academy we believe that everyone
is a learner from the teacher
perspective all of your students are
learners and you can be as well
to better understand the student
experience on khan academy log into your
khan academy account
then select the navigation button
indicated by your name on the top right
of the screen once you see the drop down
menu select learner home
you can now see the learner home page on
your screen
you can think of this as the student's
homepage as this is what students see
immediately when they log into khan
academy
also a quick tip
if the student clicks on the khan
academy logo no matter what page they
are on
assuming they are logged in they will
always be taken back to this home page
if you've never visited this page before
you will need to select at least one
course from a pop-up box screen
before you will see a screen similar to
this one
on the left hand side any classes that
the student is in
and where the teacher has given them
some sort of assignment or goal
is listed
as you can see the course mastery goals
and assignments recommended by the
teacher are accessible with a single
click
within the assignments tab learners can
easily see upcoming assignments and work
directly on the assignments from there
within the course mastery tab
learners can see the mastery goals you
have given them and their progress
towards those goals
by going to the progress tab they can
see their activity log
this same report is also available to
you as a teacher
when you click into a student on your
roster
we surface the report to both student
and teacher to facilitate accountability
and teacher student conferencing on
progress by clicking on teachers
students can see all of their current
teachers and also join a new class by
entering a class code
on this page students will find a
summary of their recent activity
energy points and badges earned
when students click on their mastery
goal they are taken to the course page
where they can work through the course
at their own pace
courses are considered complete when a
student reaches course mastery of 90 or
more
and they always have the option to go
back and view past goals
what you see here on the course page are
the different units that make up the
course
as well as the students progress towards
mastering each unit
below the unit name are the lessons
within the unit
by clicking into a lesson or unit i am
taken to the unit page
students have the option here to either
dive straight into practice which is
listed on the right hand side
or first check out the learning material
which are the articles and videos on the
left hand side
there are a couple different types of
practice content in khan academy's
mastery system
exercises which are opportunities for
students to learn single skills in
isolation
or assessments where students get mixed
skill review the different types of
assessments address different quantities
of content
quizzes are mixed review of skills in a
lesson
unit tests are mixed review of skills
within an entire unit
course challenges are mixed review of
skills from the entire course
as students work through the content
khan academy assesses their skill level
giving them a designation of attempted
familiar proficient or mastered these
levels are surfaced in the teacher
progress reports but students can also
quickly understand their level by
looking at the tower visual next to each
skill
one brick for familiar two for
proficient and the crown is unlocked at
mastered
when students work on skills in
isolation through exercises the maximum
level they can get to is proficient
they would need to answer all questions
in isolated skill practice correctly to
get to that level
the only way to get to mastered is by
proving students can ace questions
related to that skill in a mixed skill
context
so they need to complete the assessments
for that final level up
if students have tried the skill and get
70 to 99 correct we called them familiar
if they got less than 70 percent correct
then they are attempted
at the top of a course page students may
also see mastery challenges mastery
challenges are a way for students to
review and practice previously learned
skills in a course
they first get unlocked after the
student has gotten to the familiar state
on three or more skills
and continue to get unlocked once every
12 hours afterwards
they also provide another way beyond
unit tests and course challenges for
students to level up or down in already
familiar skills
mastery challenges highlight
opportunities for students to engage in
personalized space repetition of the
skills students have already started
practicing
research shows that spiraling skills
over time and across lessons is a key
component to minimizing student learning
loss and improving knowledge retention
students can see assignments from
teachers from their learner home page as
well
from the learner home page students can
select assignments from the left-hand
panel under each class
students will see current assignments in
the order of what is due soonish at the
top of the list
each assignment will show the title of
the activity the class name the due date
and time
and the status of the assignment
if the assignment is a video or article
it will show as completed or not
completed
if the assignment contains questions it
will show the student's best score
by clicking on the assignment name or
the status
which will show as a start button for
new assignments
the student will be taken directly to
the assignment
if students want to revisit past
assignments they can click the tab for
past assignments on the top of the page
when students are actively engaged with
questions through khan academy's
exercises and assessments
students receive real-time feedback and
support
if a student is stuck they are
encouraged to watch a video to help
acquire the skill needed to solve the
problem
or take a hint which walks through the
exact problem step by step
please note if the student chooses to
take a hint that question will be marked
incorrect as the final step in the hint
is the answer to the problem
once a student submits an answer they
are instantly informed if they are
correct or incorrect through an
encouraging message to move on to the
next question or reattempt the question
to reach the correct answer
we hope this video provides a better
understanding of the student experience
on khan academy
you